طاقه تعمل بالفحم لدعم معالجه النيكل
لصناعه السيارات الكهربائيه طبعا انتاج
النيكل في اندونيسيا سجل رقما قياسيا بلغ
مليون طن متري قبل عامين وتشير التوقعات
الى ارتفاع الانتاج بحلول عام
2028 الى مليونين و500 الف طن متري سنويا
في الجانب الاقتصادي ايضا اندونيسيا هي
مصدر رئيسي لنسبه كبيره من النيكل
المستخدم في بطاريات سيارات شركات مثل
تيسلا وهيونداي وفورد وتشير التوقعات الى
ارتفاع الطلب بحلول عام 2030 بنسبه اثنين
وخمسين في المئه ايضا بدات عده شركات
تستثمر في المصانع الاندونيسيه بعدما
اعلنت شركه كاتل الصينيه وشركه ال جي
الكوريه الجنوبيه وهما من اكبر مصنعي
بطاريات السيارات الكهربائيه في العالم
افتتاح مصانع في اندونيسيا قريبا بقيت
معلومه مهمه هي حجم ما يخلفه مصنع
اندونيسيا من مواد سامه يبلغ 4 ملايين طن
متري سنويا ما يكفي لملء
1667 حوض سباحه اولمبي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات